وكثفت أوكرانيا حملتها
على الفساد المشتبه به في
التجنيد العسكري، يوم الجمعة،
أقال الرئيس زيلينسكي جميع رؤساء
مراكز التجنيد الإقليمية في جميع المجالات،
واتهمهم زينسكي باستخدام وظائفهم
للتربح بينما تخوض البلاد
حربًا على الناشطين في مكافحة الفساد.
لم تكن هذه الخطوة تتعلق بالمشتبه بهم فحسب، بل تتعلق
أيضًا بالأوكرانيين العاديين. هذا
ما أخبرتني به منذ ساعة تقريبًا عندما
سألتها عن مدى أهمية قيام السيد
زيلينسكي بقمع الفساد.
فالفساد يعتبره
العديد من الأوكرانيين خيانة، خاصة في أوكرانيا.
في زمن الحرب،
فإن أي مزاعم بالفساد
تأتي بمثابة معنويات للناس،
وهناك غضب كبير
لكل أخبار عن حالات فساد،
ولهذا السبب من المهم جدًا بالنسبة للرئيس زيلينسكي
محاربة الفساد فقط
لجعل نظامهم يعمل بشكل صحيح ولكن
أيضًا  لإظهار للشعب أن
الحكومة تقوم بعملها، كان هذا
إعلانًا عامًا للغاية من قبل
الرئيس بإقالة الجميع، فهل هذا
يعني أن الجميع مذنبون
بالفساد، وجميع ضباط التجنيد لديهم
مشاكل أم أن هذه الحركة بمثابة
رسالة محليًا وإلى
الداعمين الغربيين لأوكرانيا  أعني ما هو
رد الفعل حتى الآن
لذلك نحن نتحدث عن إقالة حوالي
20 ضابطا من رؤساء
مراكز التجنيد العسكرية
أم لهذا من المهم للغاية أن
نفهم أنه ليس الجميع
متهمين بالفساد ولكن
أه الكثير منهم
وبسببهم  عدم كفاءة هذه
المراكز العسكرية أه كانت هناك
حاجة إلى أن نظهر للناس أن الحكومة
على رأس المشكلة
أه يجب أن نفهم أن
النظام هو إرث من
نظام التجنيد السوفييتي القديم ولم يكن
لدينا الوقت الكافي للقيام بذلك  الإصلاح لم
يبدأ الإصلاح إلا قبل عدة أشهر من
الغزو
وكانت
المشاكل تتراكم وكان
هناك الكثير من البيروقراطية ومزاعم
الفساد على العديد من المستويات،
وبالتالي فإن وضع أه المحاربين القدامى والجنود
الجرحى هو أيضًا علامة على أنه
كنظام يتغير وهو  سيكون
أفضل في الأشهر المقبلة
الخارجية